hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chessboard the three days of rapid
are over and after three days of rapid
Magnus cross and emerged victorious but
still we have two days of blitz left and
in those two days of lits everyone can
still grab at least 18 points since it's
a double round-robin now one with game
if you win it you get one point so here
a very nice game Magnus versus ding
again but now it's it's the Blitz
section so let's see what happens Carson
with the white pieces opens with efore
sorry about that and it's sort of out if
you hear some drilling in the background
my neighbors are drilling something so
that's just that there's no way around
it but okay with E 5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 so so far everything the same as
in their rapid game with Bishop to b5
the rule opus is on the board a 6 more
fees defense push up to a4 and Knight to
f6 now will we see another Marshall
attack and if being prepared something
for cost and other than just flying into
Constance preparation with AD Bishop
captures on d5 Magnus castles with
Bishop to e7 everything the same but now
not rook e1 and going for well inviting
ding into a second Marshall attack game
but here Magnus just captures on c6 and
ok we have D captures on c6 this is one
of the lines where it's it's better to
go with the unprincipled capturing not
towards the center I know you will
always have to capture towards the
center too to help up with a for example
this central thrust but here for example
if B captures then white can capture on
e5 so that's that's not really great
after night at first you have Ruki 1 and
black might run into some trouble so
this is never played so here we have d
capture so now the point is that if
Knight captures then you're welcome to
capture and now if rook e1 now the Queen
has access to d4 Queen d4 defends the
knight and also you weaken your f2 pawn
so that's why D captures on c6 is to be
preferred here we have d3 by Magnus and
now Knight to d7 ding makes room for the
F pawn with Knight bTW 2 and castles
biding a for preparing to grab more
space with a 5 and here
they're rook to e8 and c5 are known
moves but here dingos for a5 preventing
white from pushing a5 also stopping
before and well it is as of move 9 that
we have a completely new game so it
would seem the this time being surprised
Magnus okay we have b3 magnet Spreaker
stephene get with the dark square bishop
and then now f6 is this one of the
positions where it's actually okay to
play f6 we'll we'll see but it does
strengthen the center and the now this
Knight is free to roam around with nice
2:8 for my Magnus now the f5 square is
excellent if you wish to get away from
there you're gonna have to further
weaken your Kings side with the g6 let's
say Knight to the c5 preparing to go to
the e6 with the night and now Knight to
f5 and here like I said you either have
to give up the lights for a bishop or
further weaken your king so for the
moment the ding not interested in either
we have Knights the e6 now you can go to
d4 or f4 if needed and now Knight to c4
by Magnus a lot of horsing around but it
does prevent ideas like b5 because after
captures your a 5 point would Hank and
also it does put pressure on the center
of the board it's it's it's it's a very
nice outpost for the night so here b6
biding and now Knight captures on e7
eliminating one of the bishops and now
the night the other night will take the
place of this guy on f5 Queen captures
on e7 and now tonight's to e3 by Magnus
and now ding doesn't allow it
now g6 it was needed to further weaken
the Kings side Bishop to b2 developing
the dark square bishop and now c5 with
grabbing more control of the other d4
square maybe night the d4 will be an
idea in the future and Queen to d2 now
by Magnus connecting rooks now the other
Luke can join the game as well Bishop to
b7 now Dean connects roofs as well and
rook 81 by Magnus we have rook a to d8
and I semi open file for dings rook and
here f3 f4 would be a bit too early as
Black has complete control of DF for
square but if you look at the position
now basically the only two breakthroughs
in the position or f5 and therefore it's
hard to say who will be able to push
but here I caught a glimpse of an
interview with the Dean after the game
and here things said that he if he
thought that if he just waited then it
would be Magnus who will break through
there on the kingside and he would have
to suffer so here
ding plays a brilliant maneuver one you
would see one you would expect in a
classical game by I don't know Tigran
Petrosian or something here being plays
King to f7 and it's just a beautiful
move and dings idea is that he his king
is too vulnerable on the Kings side so
dink wants to play king of
seventy-eights the d7 to c8 and maybe
even get it to be ace to be completely
saved there because there are no good
breakthroughs for white on the Queen
side so King to f7 ding starts the King
King March with Queen to F to Magnus
wants to get to the Queen into the
attack but King e8 we have Queen to h4
by Magnus kinked at d7 now and here ding
also it almost escaped with the King so
Magnus tries to bust open the position
while the weldings King is still in the
center of the board Knight captures on
f4 and here Magnus decides to give up
the exchange rook captures on f4 we have
eight captures and now not Queen
captures to allow f5 it's a very
dangerous position for white if DF file
opens up also you don't get anything by
ecaptions' and you don't get any
discoveries because the rook on a1 is
unguarded so not something you want to
do and also after this some like 95 yes
the rook is now protected but it's black
who will be better after Bishop captures
pawn captures just move the Queen there
is no attack the king will safely hide
for example on b7 and you're still down
the exchange so Magnus goes Knight to g4
with a triple attack on the f6 pawn now
g5 by ding and Queen to h6 now this
point will fall it's not not all that
easy to guard it f5 might be an idea but
that just opens up way too many lines
you still allow the hunter piece to go
to F 2 F 6 so here Queen to east 6 ding
finds a very interesting idea he forces
the knight to capture because the knight
is now under attack
we have Knight captures with check so
King to c8 its wording wanted to go
so one little check that doesn't bother
him and here
Magnus now is done the exchange and
dings King is very safe Magnus has to be
very careful here ideas like rook to f1
are possible so so to prevent the G for
DF DF for pawn would be very vulnerable
or here
Magnus could even tried dings own idea
and try to run his King over to the
Queen side as well but Magnus plays
Queen captures on g5 he's not afraid of
the G file although it's it's a it's a
very dangerous idea to capture this
point and dink shows that immediately he
doesn't even bother to bring another
attacker into the game with rook d6 the
force the knight back he just pushes f3
right away and now you you cannot
capture because Ruby g3 or Ruby J just
wins the Queen after one one rope is
captured the other rook takes takes its
place so here we have looked the f1 by
Magnus but now rook the g8 giving back
the exchange but now the rook will wreak
havoc along the G file a knight captures
an g8 rook that's not a rook rook
captures an g8 and now well obviously
you're going to lose the g2 pawn with
check most likely here
Magnus played Queen to e5 Queen to e5 is
seemingly the same as Queen to f6 but
not really Queen to f6 is much better
well for the simple reason that it
doesn't allow the black Queen to join
the attack so here we would just see
characters captures and after the rook
eliminates the GT punking h1 will
capture some c2 you would capture on f3
and the game continues black is better
of course but still the game continues
however Magnus played Queen to e5 here
probably with the idea that after Queen
captures Bishop captures the bishop will
have an easier way of maybe joining the
defense however here ding doesn't have
to trade Queen's and of course he
doesn't he plays rook captures in g2
with check King each one and now Queen
to g6 and now it's very dangerous so
what do you do here for example if you
try something like Queen to f5 check to
trade the Queen's it's not possible just
Queen captures pawn captures and f2 wins
the game now because you've opened up
the bishops
agonal now everything like Ruby g1 is
made as it's a double check from the
rook and from the bishop so here at
Magnus played h4 he created some space
for his King if needed but now Bishop
the c6 just the safety move guarding
guarding e8 also creating a square for
his King and b7 if needed
Magnus played Queen to f4 he wants to
eliminate the f3 pawn but now rook
captures and c2 we have well now Queen
to g2 is the threat of mate so Ruth the
g1 is played but now rook back to g2
biding now threatening rook captures and
g1 and also you don't really have a you
don't really have a good good move here
just recap for some g1 is the threat you
can't really do anything so here
Magnus defended with Queen t3 now
guarding the g1 square but now it's all
over
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the quickest way to the victory
for being in this position well I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding a forced mating - and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen - g3 and now there's
nothing you can do if you if you
captured rook we already mentioned that
this is just me if you don't do it
there's no way to even for a long Queen
h4 is made Queen h3 is made even if
there should be five to try and prolong
it doesn't work now rook h2 is made so
after Queen to g3 Magnus resigned and
this is the first loss for Magnus after
after three days of rapid and this is
like the first day of blitz and this is
the first loss he suffered in in the
national library of india so a great
revenge by dink we'll see the two of
them will play one more game where ding
will have the white pieces so we'll see
how it goes
so now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I've seen a lot more wild
games have been played so we do have our
work cut out for us today but you know
feel free to use hashtag suggestion in
the description below if there's a nice
game I missed but I will try to review
them at all hopefully I would also like
to thank Stephen green for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previously
sir thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Tata Steel blitz India Edition
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and we are about to start
our next big saga so thank you all I
will season and have an excellent start
of your week